first of all
just an the debate that seemed to be a
sort of partition you've been sort of
the realist against the idealism of I
never do yes don't you think the world
needs a visit idealism no I think it
leads a bit less idealism and the 20th
century was created by idealism
communism and fascism and Nazism were
all based on idealized systems and what
the world should be ideally and how it
isn't what it is what it should be and
therefore we're entitled to change it
radically and take control of it in
order to do so and the immediate result
is genocides as we see no I think I
think idealism of bad news kind is
extremely dangerous i was there in 1968
in paris at the time when he was in the
streets shouting out his ideals and it
was enough to convert me to the other
side really know it was that bad seeing
these arrogant young people pretending
that they represented the workers
whereas in fact they were wealthy
byproducts of the middle class and
wanting to dictate to everybody a system
of politics which they had conceived
from their half-educated reading and it
stayed he stayed when that got the class
of french intellectuals ever since and i
think people like me have a duty to be
realist in opposition so look you know
this unity between the intellectuals and
the workers who was actually creating it
was you intellectuals how many workers
were involved you know very few only
those that you could control through
trade unions you know and let's get rid
of all those illusions and treat people
as they are I want to serve word crisis
surely you must think that there I think
the world today that are wrong yes of
course the lots of things that are wrong
and should be changed but the question
is how the the revolutionary way of
addressing this question is to form
together a small conspiracy of the elite
to craft a solution and then impose it
from above on the mass of mankind I take
the other view which is the classical
English view which is that people should
be given the freedom to understand their
problems and address them from their own
or existing repertoire of social and
political gestures and gradually come to
some consensus and that that is a very
different approach so this absolutely
you're not saying that love you need a
new aristocracy know things of course
would be better if if I had more of a
voice than I do but there's no way which
that can happen but you know I'm lucky
that the Nexus Institute allows me to
speak but in my book on green philosophy
I do describe what I think of as an
alternative to these top-down solutions
so the big problems of the environment
and how am I alternative is to make the
space for ordinary motives of ordinary
people to take charge of the problem and
how would they take charge well the
problem first of all has to be local and
I think this is one thing I agree with
about in what bad you said in his in his
lecture which is that the dome the great
points of transition in communities and
also in individuals are local that they
involve some some problem that you are
living through and which you which also
makes you recognize your dependence upon
other people how you need them to join
with you in order to solve this problem
and at the Dutch did this very well in
the 17th century they had a huge
environmental problem I've drool and
they built the dikes to solve it these
are one of the great achievements that
was not done by some committee of
revolutionary
Vanguard imposing upon the ordinary
Dutch people a solution they didn't want
it was ordinary people locally getting
together to build their own dike and
gradually the country I solved its
problem and I think many of our
environmental problems today can be
confronted in that way as long as you
keep those intellectuals out of them
finally you mentioned that you think the
sacred should return to our societies
play that yes I I think human beings are
incomplete without a concept of the
sacred then they must have a sense that
that this world in which they live has
moments places events people etc which
are in some sense standing outside the
ordinary course of events they're not
just things to be bargained with things
to be bought and sold but as it was
stand in judgment on us and all of us
have that sense when we're children
because that is instinctive in us but
it's wiped away by a materialism and by
the ease of the the ease of satisfying
our wants and so on and the result is
where that we are in a certain measure
bereft bereft of something that is
needed for our happiness which is the
sense that we are in good relations with
sacred things